gamespot's star wars battlefront
marathon brought to you by Duracell
starts now it's just this for six hours
yeah that's about it yes yes oh go rob
go all rights little his car hey thank
you my ship no my dress blowing that's
pretty amazing oh yeah oh he ran into me
they cross directly into the mountain I
think Ribeiro rolled into the mountain
haha alright who are we trying to kill
Vader later hey I don't know him oh oh
oh no I have the ion thing are no joke
gosh I thought I was gonna like skunk Oh
remember come and get me I've got a
battle droid you will die what haha
we're in your kill it there's that group
you were kind of looking at yeah yeah
there I'm just strafing them on other oh
hey OH
wait let's talk let's do a survival
let's do survival not great shooting but
it's okay all this guy Oh get domed
that's why you were a helmet Baldy
mm-hmm so sorry all right watch this
you're gonna cool cool move here here we
go that was a cool move you were right
Oh what you got speeder bike yep all
right I'm trying to let me try some here
I'm gonna go around through that oh are
you honking that's all we went through
before after that way hey no I'll follow
you because what you're the frontline
dude no but your way your apprentice man
yeah exactly you do what I say all right
go on front haha that is hilarious boba
has a response up there is this how they
did it there's a shot oh yeah he's
telling me to come on guys is doing
this is a sign of victory when when all
these guys are out there some boba fett
is the only one shooting dudes
what are you doing why do they keep
running out here there's another one
gonna do it yes what's going on what's
happening they just keep running into
someone I keep shotgunning them over the
head guy coming from the lecture not
less precisely don't worry they found
out hahaha rom mrs. you sent me the box
oh and he's got
hey this guy's didn't like slid on his
eat oh [ __ ] mm-hmm that was [ __ ]
hilarious no time for hilarity Robert
gamemode dance program we all know that
song I think this is a great song to
close out the stream on don't you rob I
do big thanks to Duracell for sponsoring
this star wars marathon here for Rob
handlery I'm Chris waters thank you all
for watching all of our rebels vs
Imperial action have fun in battlefront
yourself and we'll see you soon take
care
you